Let me see. Rich Campbell, guys. Brand new announcement today.
People are freaking out. The Aelia Lexi person, who is the person
who actually accused Rich Campbell originally back in December
of 2022, came out today said, "I decided to dis to dismiss my
lawsuit against Rich Campbell. No payment was offered by either
of us to the other. I want to thank everyone for their support
over this difficult period, and I wish him well in his future
endeavors." Now, a lot of people are very triggered about specifically
this, right? I wish him well in his future endeavors. Every response
I've seen, literally every response is, "Wait, he he's your and
you wish him well in his future endeavors."
I think there's a reason. I think there's a reason this would
have happened to be honest with you.
How long does this lawsuit go on for? Like two years, probably.
Two years, two and a half years. You ruined his life. Okay, hold
on. She made her allegations.
I'll just say factually you don't know that she lied about him,
right? You don't know that he that she lied. I don't think there
was a lot of evidence on her side, but you you have no idea if
she lied or not, right? Like she could be telling the truth.
It's just a matter of how guilty can somebody be in a he said,
she said, right? Like how how guilty can the public hold somebody
in that case? And when that happens, when it is purely a he said,
she said like this case, right?
You absolutely
you absolutely have to have good friends and good I guess um
co-workers and people around you, right? There's not really a
whole lot of evidence on his side. It's it's like testimony from
a roommate or something. Moody Morgan. Um
yeah, I've got the Tik Tok stuff. I've got the Tik Tok stuff.
We can do it later.
Uh I think I'm going to have to get more aggressive about timing
people out when I'm setting up a new story. I'm going to I might
just go back and like restart this again. If I'm setting something
up and people are asking about other stories instead of the one
I'm currently doing, I'm just going to start like timing out
for an hour or something. We'll see if that gets it out of the
Just don't reply. I can't I see it. I see it and I can't not
reply. Okay. To ADHD. We That's what we might need. We might
need a chat that doesn't respond. Sure. Okay. Anyway, so I was
responding to stuff about Rich Campbell.
Um let's see here. I thought the roommate heard everything. Okay.
So, here was overdosing.
Is that more than a he said she said in that situation? Rich's
Rich's roommate says, "Oh, well, I didn't I I heard them having
and it sounded like they were having a good time." Is that Is
that
Can that really mean something in the same way that I don't know.
I I feel like that that is the piece of evidence that kind of
cut in Rich's way, though, was the roommate said, "Well, I thought
she was there and she wanted to have I don't know if she disagreed.
I guess her statement said she didn't want to have sex when she
went there. I think her actions sort of don't represent that
very well if we go through the original um allegations, right?
She goes there like very late at night. He's clearly pushing
for I think there's some understanding going on there that is
not necessarily explicit, but it is implicit, right? Okay. Anyway,
so she announced today that she's dropping her lawsuit. She had
a lawsuit against Rich and Rich had a counter suit against her.
Rich's countersuit was
I think three months ago. Okay, let me find the article here.
Rich had his own
Three months ago, One True King co-founder tenatively settles
defamation suit against accuser.
August 7th, 2025. Founding member of the media organization One
True King has tenatively settled a defamation lawsuit against
a fellow influencer in which he alleged the woman falsely accused
him of rape in retaliation for not making the romantic commitment
to her that she
So, let's see here.
Rich Campbell's Los Angeles Superior Court lawsuit against Aelia
Alexi also alleged contract interference and intentional infliction
of emotional distress. On July 31st, his attorneys filed court
papers with Judge Upbrinder Appender S. Kaira, notifying this
judge of a conditional resolution in the case with the expectation
a with the expectation a request for dismissal will be filed
by September 15th. No terms were revealed. Uh, it's got Lex's
real name here. So, I'm going to scroll down a little bit more.
But in a suit filed in December 2023, Campbell said Lexi's allegations
were false where those of a superfan or groupy who has consensual
with her crush, in this case, a popular influencer, demands more
of her crush's time than he can give. And then,
oh, in his suit filed a year after. And then when he rejects
her demands for a serious relationship, retaliates against him
by trying to tarnish his reputation and have him canceled by
posting lies on the internet accusing him of Campbell is a popular
social media influencer. Kind of was.
See, we got anything else going on here? Flight attendant made
posts about this. We'll we'll go through the actual timeline
and stuff as well in a little bit, but there's the there's the
original stuff all laid out, right? the original
accusations. I do want to go through her actual statement in
a little bit. Rich is coming back. Well, funny enough, when this
came out, Asmin Gold made a state. Sorry, not Asmin Gold. Techone
made a statement about it here. Let's give it a quick look on
Twitter. >> In December of this, this is around the exact
same time. I believe it was like later in a >> 2022, Rich
Campbell, co-founder of One True King OTK, was publicly accused
of SA by Twitch streamer
Lexi. And nearly 3 years later on August the 27th in 2025, fellow
streamer at Techton claimed that during a >> so Tech had
heard about this and 20 days later he had posted about it. He
he had a stream comment where he says, "I heard Rich won his
court cases and he's coming back soon." >> That Campbell
had been having success in his legal battles. According to TechTome,
he heard that Campbell had won almost all the cases. He didn't
lose a single one and he might be returning to streaming. But
in recent news, in
>> so I don't think that's true. I think all cases have
been dismissed now, right? I think basically every case has been
dismissed. It's all dismissed. Nobody won. Unless you want to
say that mutually dismissing your lawsuits is winning. I don't
I don't think that's really winning. >> Lexi directly refuted
those assertions and she said in the following, "This is not
true and thank you for bringing this to my attention so I can
relay this to my counselor on." >> So she responds by saying,
"Why would she relay this to her counsel?" Uh, Riyle, I assume
this would have to do with with Tech's obligations to OTK when
he leaves and that OTK members, OTK representatives, obviously
very likely would have been barred from making comments on this
that they might have had inside knowledge. I'm guessing there
would be a thing where you'd have like some kind of NDA. Um,
this would be like somebody very close to who you're suing breaking
a non-disclosure agreement or breaking some cone of silence in
a way that's like bad for your case, right?
I assume that and maybe she just wanted a front too. She might
have just wanted a front to be honest. But then again, that's
back in August. On August 27th, she says that it's not done yet.
So as of about 3 months ago, sorry, two and a half months ago,
no two months ago. Sorry, my timeline is horrible. Uh two months
ago, she said it was not done yet.
All right.
uh there's a lot of responses going on. Okay. We're we're seeing
a lot of responses. Very aggressive responses.
Another Only Fans woman lying about and then just moves on. No
damage done to them. Ruined a man's life for 3 years. Why is
this so common? Why is it so common? One, Rich did not have to
leave, right? I I if I were Techone, I would look at the management
of OTK that I think pressured Rich to just go away, right? And
honestly, once we get through all this, I wouldn't be shocked
if that's one of the reasons that Asminold's picked off at Misk.
So Tee's life has not been ruined.
Rich's life has been ruined. And what's the difference between
Rich's situation and Te's situation? It's how Rich's friends
and co-workers and how his his members, I guess, fellow founders
of OTK reacted to that news.
That's that's the difference between the Tee situation and the
rich situation. Uh that we could speak to directly. Um actually,
Teone also lied about his own situation. said he could totally
uh what would you call it? Totally exonerate himself and then
produced no evidence that exonerated himself. Right. Rich shut
the [__] up and sued.
So Tees actually it you know worse in in nearly every way. Real
realistically OTK cut off the wrong guy. What I'm saying but
this is what a lot of people are saying is is oh she accused
him of something with no evidence and oh it's soed up and he
ru she ruined his life.
I don't I have a different way of looking at it. I think the
the allegation could or couldn't be true. We really don't know.
And realistically, the thing that Rich was the response of his
organization and his peers. There's no evidence she lied. Exactly.
It's like still fairly neutral, right? It's still a he said,
she said. Now, I would imagine if we look at this statement closely,
I've decided to dismiss my lawsuit against Rich Campbell. No
payment was offered by either of us to the other. I want to thank
everyone for their support over this difficult period, and I
wish him well in his future endeavors. This to me screams we've
settled both cases out of court. We have agreements out of court,
but they weren't um they aren't like court adjudicated. Oh, actually
true tourniquet. Rich managed to get through this without trying
to pander to any groups. He didn't he didn't about face as a
Republican. He didn't come back as a Christian and how talk about
how his faith saved him from these evil succubi, right? He didn't
do any of that cringe bull. So realistically, I still like Rich.
Rich was charismatic. Rich was funny as I like Rich's stream
when I used to watch that kind of stuff. He was a he was an amazing
esports host. His his Dota 2 esports like hosting was second
to none. He did a great job. Okay. It's very sad to me that unfortunately
he seems to be aligned with Asmin Golden Techone. I really hope
he can separate himself slightly. Um oh, Trucker Joe, don't worry.
We will get to the Asmin Gold statement soon enough. Okay, we
will get to the Asmin Gold statement where he very nearly cries.
It seems like I'm a little concerned that this video might get
taken down at some >> I think everybody >> about
Rich about Rich, guys. >> I think everybody's pretty much
seen the allegations and everything against Rich. Uh if you haven't,
uh I would suggest to just check our Twitter. Uh and damn
So, we will check this out in just a little bit. I do need to
grab really quickly this video before it possibly gets deleted.
So, give me a second. I'm going to start downloading that. Uh,
and that is Is it downloading? It's downloading. Nope. Error.
Unable to 403. Okay. Shut up.
>> Do not 403. Do not 403. >> You know, we've obviously
addressed this >> Oh, we're not going here yet. I needed
to I think what we should do here is we should look at a few
of the responses to her message. Just see how crazy people are.
Okay. And then I'm going to go through and I think we should
walk through the Rich Campbell allegations and see how they actually
came out,
I'll look for we can look for other reactions as well as we go.
I got a couple from around the time just like some LSF threads
and stuff. We can look for more reactions from around that time.
I would be interested in what TechOne said at that time if anybody
could find it. But let's uh let's take a look. Original Twit
Longer. No, no, no. Hold on. This is just one of the other big
responses. I saw this Proborn YouTube guy. This I don't know
who this guy is. Pro Reborn.
Oh, he's not even big. This is on my first page. That's crazy.
No, I don't accept this result. You accused him of He lost everything.
Absolutely everything is a result of it. It should end with someone
in prison. Either him as a felon or you for felony perjury. Felony.
Again, I said this at the time. There is some there is something
to be said for like, oh, it is like a he said, she said. It's
not a part of any bigger thing.
I like you can you can wait on this and say like, "Oh, we obviously
respect like the situation she's going through, right? Rich did
not have to leave. You didn't have to just go."
Yeah, I've seen the counter suit documents as well. Trucker Joe,
I don't think that's like quite as interesting. It was cool at
the time because we didn't have any resolution. It was good to
get um new stuff. All right. Jesus Christ.
Okay. Felony perjury claims should never end with. I wish him
well in his in his future as a conclusion from the plaintiff.
Are you kidding me? Um, by the way, there's also the chance that
she just doesn't want to get harassed off of the internet because
she might still I don't know if she still does like modeling
or only fans or whatever the but like if she does, she might
just want it to not be supering the internet for her, right?
She might not really wish anybody well uh wish anybody well.
It's entirely possible. All right, let's look at the uh
the Asmin Gold uh the Asthma Gold subreddit's response. Oh, also
the Asmin Gold response, which I think leads me to believe that
some of these agreements involved OTK as well. Okay, let me pull
this up. This is the Asmin Gold response today. What do you guys
think the Asmin Gold response was? What do you guys think?
It's really easy to predict. You probably know cuz I'm asking.
All right, the response was uh lawsuit. Lawsuit. >> Now,
what is this here? I want to say, guys, and I know you might
not want to hear this. I cannot comment on this for legal reasons.
End of discussion. Any I think to make some of this stuff go
away, they just all agreed to sign non-disparagement, non-disclosure
agreements, and that was just it. Just nobody talked about this.
It's like a situation that can't be resolved. Let's just all
move on with our lives, right? We have we've done all this litigation
over years. Let's just all move on. Yeah. Okay. Let's see asold
response. I was just going to look at the Aspold subreddit because
I'm sure there's going to be some really really intelligent,
really great discussion happening here about the like how you
should react to any sort of allegation and how you should evaluate
those statements over time, right? Any new facts that come to
light, I'm sure it's going to be really enlightened discussion.
I wish him well. Yeah, good luck after oblitting the man's reputation
forever.
I don't think his reputation is
That's that's the sad thing is I don't think his reputation was
obliterated by this. Um except for the fact that he didn't go
and try to fight for his reputation at all. How should you react?
Um I think I think this is everybody wanting to move on. I I
personally believe Rich should have come out and said I didn't
do that. He should have had some statement right
now. There's a reason he made no statements.
What is that reason? It's not because that was the best choice.
I think almost anybody could have seen that making a statement
making a pre-statement saying I'll respond and then never responding
for years.
That's not a good plan. Or or only responding with your lawsuit
a year later. Like that is not a good plan
in my opinion. I think this is what I think. I think he had shares
in OTK and they probably told him, "We can cut you now and and
keep your shares for ourselves or if you want to if you want
to just shut the up while litigation is pending or while lawsuits
are pending, then you can keep your shares in OTK." And I'm guessing
around that time it looked like OTK was going to be worth a lot.
Don't know how much it's worth now. Ah, but I I have a feeling
it's something like that. Like, hey, we can cut you out or you
can keep your shares and just shut the up and take whatever heat
from this you're going to. Nice of you to say after destroying
his personal career reputation of his former org OTK.
Wait, is it Msk? I I can't tell. Are the Asminol people saying
Miskf OTK or Rich? At this rate, I feel like she won enough by
accusing him and ruining his entire life and reputation. Weird
thing to say for such a massive accusation.
Again, I think I think the way she said that to me points at
a settlement of some kind that included non-disparagement clauses
that she just was like, "Oh, I want to move on from this. I wish
him well." Blah, blah, blah. Let me get out of here. That's that's
what it seems like to me. Anyone disagrees with that, throw a
theory in the chat. But I I can't see her like truly wishing
him well, right? I can't see that being the case. Around the
time Teone got kicked out of OTK, Asmin made a video where he
said he had multiple friends he had cut ties with because their
lives got ruined by baseless allegations and he was sick of it.
Wouldn't surprise me if Rich was someone on that list. Rich was
transparently obviously somebody on that list. Yes. Yeah. He
was obviously referring to Rich there. And I pointed this out
at the time when we saw that with the techone stuff. Asher's
bow. I saw this um when we
uh at the time when Asmin Gold made that statement. I said, "Bro,
you're the guy who rolled on Rich. If you had just stood tall
for Rich, like you stood tall for Miskf." Like people in OTK
stood tall for Msk, right? Msk had way more evidence of his bad
conduct than there was against Rich. Rich is the person you should
have stood tall for. You guys rolled on him. You guys made him
leave,
That's how it is. It's you guys. It's OTK that was the differentiator
between uh Teone situation and Rich's and then Rich's situation
and Misks. It's their inability to evaluate the information that's
coming out and make a good decision. And Asminold can blame that
on the people making the allegations as much as he likes, but
if he had stood by Rich, Rich would have been fine. Rich could
have kept streaming. It would have all been it would have all
been fine. And you could have let the information play out as
it was going to play out or let the the case play out as as it
was going to play out. Stole the equity input. No, no, no. I
think Wired Rope I don't know if you're referring to something
else, but I don't think uh
I don't think that they took his equity away. In fact, I'm pretty
sure that it came out, it was evident like way after this, like
in 2024 or 2023, that Rich still had a lot of equity in OTK if
I'm not mistaken. All right, let me take a look at Oh, a couple
more here.
Wonder if Rich will return to streaming or not. Techone thinks
he'll return. And I think Tech talks to him. Techone talks like
he's close friends with Rich. I want to hear Sir talking about
this. He acted like Rich never existed. At least Nick and Soda
called him redacted and joke about him a couple of times, but
Sir was like, "Who is Rich?"
Uh, I miss AllCraft Podcast. Not a fan of Rich, but what was
the point then? I was a huge fan of Rich. Yeah, I understand
exactly why they did it, BB Poison.
But ultimately
ultimately that organization ran through Asmin Gold from start
to finish anyway. I understand why they felt they had to do it.
I understand that Miskf probably pushed for it. Like we can't
take anything else right now. I understand that everybody there
probably wishes they let Msk go and helped Rich, right? But I
Oh, the Bruce I don't think the Bruce thing played into it that
much either. But I understand that they they couldn't they felt
like they didn't have the capital with their audience to um
to to keep defending people, right? But the funny thing is is
Asingold then just burned all of that like any part of that community
that would have cared about rich Asold burned that all the way
anyway himself, right, with his
So like it was for nothing. I understand how the management of
OTK could have come to that conclusion. I totally do. But I'm
saying that because they came to that conclusion which wasn't
based on fairness to Rich at all. Wasn't based on fairness in
any sense. Right.
Because they came to that conclusion.
Rich got destroyed. Oh, here's techone on Rich at the time, by
the way. Oh, what? No way. Hold on.
No way.
>> Oh, let's go.
Oh, I'm excited now. I am very excited now. So, the first thing
we'll do is we'll read the original Aelia Alexi post. I could
have sworn there was a more detailed post that came out. This
one didn't seem that long. So, we'll give this a read and then
we'll go through the asenold detected reactions back then. Maybe
some other reactions. We'll just kind of take a walk through
history. Okay, that's that's what I want to do for the next little
bit here. Let me see. Original Twit Longer. Let's give this a
read.
Oh, whoops. Where's my archive post? I've got it somewhere archived
here, don't I? I do, but I I minimized it. Hold on.
Hold on. Appear. Appear. Load. Thank you.
Here we go. Here we go. Here we go. Please load. Shouldn't have
closed this at the time. We're waiting. Here we go. All right.
Here we go. Okay.
If you want the whole account, here it is. Oh, this comes from
a tweet.
Is this I've got the old LSF thread that'll have her tweet. Her
tweet wasn't very long. She also had another tweet before this
that was talking about how Rich had assaulted her. It was just
like a one-off. It didn't include a tweet longer. Here's the
original LSF thread. So, if you want to read the whole account,
here it is. Oh, it's the same thing. So, she accused Rich and
then she says, "Here's the whole story."
Let's give it a look. This was before Tee learned of his past
and his father. Okay. Rich and I had a very up and down on andoff
friendship and relationship for four years that started towards
the end of his career on the Call of Duty desk. Our physical
relationship started in Columbus, Ohio in 2019 and was a disaster
from there. Without going into extensive detail, because that's
what would be required to explain it. There were several times
during the four years that he made it clear he only viewed me
as a object. But when I would confront him about it, I would
get lovebombed and gaslit into thinking that he cared about me
and wanted to be with me. This would happen during the single
periods of my life as anytime I would be in a relationship. Oh,
sorry. This would happen during the single periods of my life
as anytime I would be in a relationship and he would text or
call me, I would tell him I was seeing someone else. After he
lied to me about having a girlfriend for an extended amount of
time in June of 2021, I didn't speak to him or see him until
he called me asking to apologize around the end or uh end of
July/ beginning of August. This would be in 2022
or possibly a month later. The allegation happens in 2022. I
assume this is July or August of 2022, implying like a period
of almost a year where they didn't speak. Oh, nope. I lied. It's
going to make sense now as we go down to here. Oh, right. Because
the allegation happens quite a bit after the actual assault.
So, about a month later, he calls to apologize.
Uh, I always had a deep love for Rich as a person and friend.
As the beginning of our friendship, he was there for me like
not a lot of people are. So, I gave him another chance to be
friends. He told me he would prove to me that he was working
on being a better person and that he wanted to be in my life.
Then in October, he began his typical antics and begged me to
come to Texas around his uh sunbatheon.
Sunbaathon.
Subathon. Maybe just sub. Maybe just subathon. I thought it was
maybe a tanning subathon, but probably a subathon. I said no
because I did not think it was appropriate to stay with him because
I did not want to sleep with him and I did not trust him. He
also came to LA in December of 2021 and asked to see me, but
mainly was only asking me to come to his hotel. I said no due
to the fact that I was not interested in having sex with him.
So again, she believes that going to meet Rich, he only wants
and that meeting up with him would be wanting to have sex with
him. This was the the core thesis is like she understands that
Rich only wants to see her to have she she understands that.
And so later on when she decides to go see him late at night
after having a couple drinks, it's it seems likely to me that
she's not going to see him not for like or she understands it's
on the table in some way.
Okay. There was not much communication until I was at a French
restaurant AOC in the Upper East Side of January on January 30th
of this year, 2022 with two girlfriends. As the night came to
an end around 12:00 a.m., I Ubered to Rich's apartment in Williamsburg
because he asked to see me. We were in the movie theater in his
building and talking about uh talking and he repeatedly kept
attempting to get me to lay on him. I repeatedly said, "I'm not
here to sleep with you and I do not want that." At one point
in the theater, he said, "I think tonight is the last time I'm
I'm ever going to see you after trying to speak to him for an
hour about our relationship and the awful way he treated me.
He just continued to deflect and said there's no reason to talk
about it because it makes him feel bad." He said we he said that
we couldn't stay in that room and needed to go up to his apartment
per the apartment rules. I said I don't trust that he uh I don't
I said I don't trust that. and he promised me that that was the
situation that nothing would happen and he was respecting the
boundary I set we get. So again, now given this, it doesn't make
it okay. Even though I think Rich wants to go upstairs upstairs
for I think it's very likely he's lying, it doesn't make his
lying okay, right? But when she goes upstairs, I feel like she
has all the information to know who this guy is. We get upstairs
and he starts talking about how how hot I would be pregnant.
He then proceeded to jerk off in front of me while continuing
to talk about how he thinks about getting me pregnant constantly.
He kept begging me to have with him. I said no. He continually
attempted to take my clothes off. I kept saying no. At the end,
and I mean at the very end, he rolled me over and put himself
inside me and finished unprotected. Afterwards, I called my friend
who I was staying with so I could come back and and she wasn't
answering because it was late at night and she was already asleep.
Rich said I couldn't stay there, so I called hotels around New
York City looking for a cheap hotel room. I asked for the nearest
subway and it was a 20-minute walk. Without anything said without
saying anything to him, I left and cried in his lobby as he texted
me, "You okay?" I never replied. I left, went to a sketchy hotel
in Chinatown, and processed it by myself. I left New York the
next day, and never spoke to Rich again. I am a 30-year-old woman
in a relationship with someone currently. I have had several
relationships with people that just simply did not work out,
and I still respect those people and would never make a false
claim based on a relationship ending. I get nothing out of lying
about this. In fact, it's almost expected to receive it's almost
expected to receive ridicule when speaking about assault. You
can believe me or not, I genuinely don't owe anyone anything
and I'm not here to beg people to believe me. Okay. Okay. Uh,
wait, he didn't. Yeah, he did not let her stay after. That's
kind of weird to say that, right? To not let her stay there.
Now, there were I believe there were text messages shown after
this, right? How did she get naked? I believe he said she said
he pulled her clothes off, right? Yeah. Finally attempted to
take my clothes off. I kept saying no at the end. And I mean
at the very end. So, he was very likely pressuring. I have no
idea if he would have
like
it's possible that this situation ends up murky, right? Because
he pressures the whole time and then eventually she says, "Oh,
okay. I guess like something." Not a good situation. Also, yes,
Archangel, this is obviously true. But don't point it out to
people. They'll get scared. You have forbidden knowledge.
Okay. I don't know how I would find the text messages attached
to this cuz it seems like she's deleted a lot of the the original
tweets. So, we'd have to go back and try to find the original
text messages. I don't know where they are. I didn't go look
for them after this. I believe the text messages
are a little murky. Not in that they don't show anything cuz
he was she was sending like selfies to him that night like they
were talking back and forth and then it does seem like she leaves
and and tries to find like a hotel or something. So basically
he's guilty of being a piece of I mean that seems like the most
likely outcome to me is there were some crosswires and he kind
of is a piece of who is consistently pushing her boundary that
he agreed to respect.
That seems to be the most likely outcome to me which is yeah
he's a piece of and yeah it's bad. Yeah, I think it's understandable
and that's why again I don't think Rich should have been cancelled
or forced to stop streaming in any way because of this because
to me I could understand how both sides of this would would feel
like they have a a remembrance of this of this occasion where
they both think they're they haven't done anything wrong and
the other person has wronged them. Sounds like a if we believe
her. She says she keeps saying no. I'm saying that if you if
you think all of this is 100% accurate, then yeah, it sounds
like now the roommate was there that night, I believe. Wasn't
there supposed to be several other victims that never came out?
Um, I don't know about that. Where was that Todd Bronson?
There there definitely weren't more people who came out. Now,
maybe perhaps we'll see this in the Asmin Gold or Teone reactions
to this information.
She's framing it as well, it's consent violation. It's it's boundary
pushing,
Um, I think there's there's some
question about what this is strictly under the law, right? Because
she could easily be leaving out something where she's like, "Fine,
right, fine." or something.
Under the law, I don't know that you could prove that he was
never taking no for an answer and there was no consent at all.
Right? This is why when you're in a situation like this with
somebody who has shown that they can't keep to their word about
not making
you shouldn't go up to a hotel room at midnight to hang out with
them after watching a movie, going to their place at midnight
to watch a movie and then go up to their hotel room. Unfortunately,
you do just have to call it cuz this person has shown that they
won't respect your your boundaries at all. They've shown that
repeatedly
and now it's like, well, we can't really prove what happened.
We we just can't we don't we don't know for sure in either direction.
Not a hotel. Oh, sure. Apartment. Yeah. Apartment. And then not
leave when they start off in front of you. Yeah. There's a lot
of there's a lot of things going on where
it's just difficult to know where this is. Like this it's an
it's an ambiguous situation. It's gray situation. It's up. And
it it could be possible that this was far more physically violating
than she's even letting on here, right? It could even be more
more egregious in her direction with details she's not revealing.
Right. I find that less likely based on the tone, the context
I'm seeing here through the whole thing. I I tended to think
this was a situation where it was pressuring and she probably
felt like
he was pressuring and and maybe looking to start something new
and then he kind of was like, "No, but you can't stay here after
they'd have." And it was like super triggering at that point
for him to be like actually right cuz she did she wanted something
more
and and then they end up having and then he's like yeah you can't
stay here. Sorry that's that's got to be kind of rough you know.
So I understand how she contextualized this as like a a major
violation.
Is it a lawful violation?
I don't I I tend to think not but I I don't know would be the
primary answer. Right. There's a big area of unknowns and then
my my leaning towards it not being um like a legal violation
is probably bigger than my leaning towards it being a actual
legal violation. I sent an article snippet about it, but all
the clips and links are now dead. Uh-oh. Twitch streamer Casey
Tron talks about Rich Campbell and claims there were several
other victims. During a live stream on December 5th, 25th, 2022,
Twitch streamer Casey Caseyron chimed in on the controversy and
alleged that there were several other victims with corroborating
factors to their stories. She claimed that another victim had
a similar story to Aelia Alexi. It was relayed to me by Alexi
that Asmin Gold communicated to her that there were several other
victims and that there are corroborating factors in each story.
She told me that she is also aware of one other victim that she
has a similar theater story to hers and others that have stated
he finished in them without their consent. I've personally seen
a few of these tweet longers from two different women who eventually
went private and deleted their statements. Oh, wait. Do we see
this? Two different women, two different twitongers about Rich.
Oh, I don't remember. I don't remember any of that. Like the
other twitongers that were attached. Would you would you think
that baby poisoned that she'd be a piece of Wouldn't she feel
kind of like left alone on an island when she made the public
allegation and those people kind of like publicly stood up and
then retracted and left her standing there alone as like the
sole person making the allegation and that's how it's been framed
to everybody including courts for like a long time now? I don't
know. It was kind of a different way to think about it. Anyway,
let's get back to now knowing that knowing that Casey Tron said
that I guess I want to see Asminold's response and I want to
see if Asminold
how does he respond to this? Cuz are we going to are we going
to see this on his face that he feels like Rich is cooked that
there are more allegations and that Rich is totally
if I remember correctly he was uh he was pretty upset. Actually,
I'm going to I'm going to leave the asen stuff for after. I want
to watch TechTone first. Also, I need to use the bathroom really
quickly. So, I need to use the bathroom real quick. I'm gonna
hit play on Techone. I'll be right back. Give me 30 seconds.
I might grab some more water and caffeine, too. Okay, be right
back. >> I'll probably
know what's going on.
I'm sure you guys realize that
the actions of one person affect a lot more than just one person.
Unfortunately, going to be a lot of things coming to an end.
Was 8 minutes.
I was 8 minutes into my stream yesterday. 8 minutes.
And then I say
the [__]
the stuff that we're going to talk about.
Uh,
now I want to talk about what a lot of people here are here to
hear about.
Um, and that way in case that's all they care, you know, they
can go about their
Um, let's talk about Rich. Okay. Uh, I want to make one thing
perfectly clear. >> [__] about to cry again.
God damn it. How is he always crying?
>> I've seen a lot of people
>> who like to go online.
>> And say,
>> Techone, you're a [__] grown ass dude, man.
You're a grown ass man.
Sorry, Jeff. This is a very touchy >> Statements he's made
about his ex. >> That truly does not help anything. People
should not have to be afraid of telling their stories online.
>> Trucker Joe, unfortunately, we can't hit him.
Me when my dad is kind of true, BB poison. Yes, but I can't tag
him. He's got me blocked. Okay. Doesn't like people who criticize
him. >> Oh jeez. Second time in a year I've had to talk
about this. It's really bad. As a lot of you all know,
>> I
have been affected by
assault.
my life multiple times.
>> I have also
in I also
>> Now the real crime here is that we don't have the uncensored
version of this VOD. I'm going to need that for a soundboard.
I'm going to need I need it for a soundboard. I'm sorry. >> And
I know the feeling when you share your story online or with your
family and people don't want to believe you, it
>> Okay, hold on. I understand that this wouldn't be um
it's something that it's difficult to laugh about or joke about
if this person had any consistency to these beliefs if they weren't
inter entirely internally motivated. Right? I would say it's
completely inappropriate to mock him in any way. And you don't
have to mock him for being a victim of any of this. You have
to mock him for using it publicly to drive sentiment in his direction
every single time over every single issue. He is always going
to use these things to try to like boost the viewers, boost the
subs,
and he's got positions that are completely incompreh completely
oh, what would you say? They can't be reconciled, right? He's
got
like issues. Contradictory. That's the one. Contradictory positions.
Okay.
again, it's it's hard to remember who Teone has become and
keep that context when you watch him cry like this. All right.
a lot of bravery to share those things. And just because someone
waits a little bit
doesn't mean that it's not true.
It doesn't mean that it is true. But we should not shame anybody
who is sharing their story.
Realistically, maybe we shouldn't even be mocking this. This
is probably the position you should have, right? The issue with
how these things get resolved is like the rest of the world's
response and how specifically in a lot of cases how like employers
and professional contacts respond that they all disconnect from
the person. Oh, that person's too toxic. Right? That's that's
the thing is that's the thing that needs to be controlled when
it's just like a pure he said she said like this
and Tekan's a part of the organization that left Rich on an island.
>> We trust
we trust
and then we confirm. believe that's how this I believe that's
how the saying goes in case you guys don't know.
>> Wait, was Tekton also a communist? Trust but verify.
>> It took me
13 years 13 years
to talk about my own. And so when people want to use that as
an issue, it takes some it takes some time. It takes some time
for people.
>> Hold on. I'm I'm sending this time stamp to Shimu right
now. So please,
if you see men or women sharing their stories online about your
favorite content creators, you can say nothing if you like. But
you really shouldn't tell these people
you're lying. Let people speak their truth. But another Only
Fans woman lying about and then just moves on.
Oh, wait. Another one. Who's the other one? Is the other one
your ex-girlfriend techone that you're saying she's lying? Are
you just saying she's lying?
You encouraging your audience to go online and say she's lying.
Wow. >> People speak their perspectives. That's what I
will say on that part. Oh, I swear to God. Oh, I talk it on streams.
Makes it all come out, bro. [__] So, I was good.
I was good all day. I was good all day. All right, chat.
You all know that's a very very touchy subject for me. Y'all
know that's a very touchy subject for me. >> Ah, really
poor phrasing there. What are you doing, man? >> Okay,
now let's just [__] calm down. I want to talk about
Rich Campbell. Now, the feeling that I felt yesterday was kind
of like uh better yet, I can show y'all a really cool anime reference.
>> dude,
uh >> so this is kind of how I felt like yesterday to put
it into words. Let's get some >> now. Now he just has the
anime references as tattoos, guys. Okay. >> Good old anime,
you know. Let's get some good old anime. That'll be fun.
>> Like that.
>> This is how he found out about hearing when he heard
Rich was accused of Okay. This is what happened to his heart.
>> Like this.
>> It was like this. That's what happened to his heart
when he heard the Rich Campbell news. Okay, guys.
>> I just kind of felt like [__]
And I don't I don't really know how to feel. I still don't know
how to feel to be honest. But as y'all know, I mean, Rich was
one of my best friends.
what do you mean was? What do you mean was? He's accused with
no You've seen no evidence or you've seen evidence and you've
never shared it with anybody, but apparently you've seen no evidence.
There is no evidence against him. There is no like solid evidence
of any kind. I don't even think the text messages would have
been released at this point. And you've dumped this guy already
just purely for I guess your streaming
>> I mean I I considered
rich like a brother. Very rare I have that in my life. I mean
that guy was with me through like my entire divorce and it sucks.
Am I speaking to him? >> No. What's done is done. >> What?
What do you mean what's done is >> And we >> This
is the other thing by the way. Like this is him. He cannot
for one do not accept him for one second. Virtue signaling over
rich when this is a part of the cancellation. This is as big
a part of the cancellation as any other person contributed except
maybe Lexi with the actual allegation. Right? When he just totally
throws this guy under the bus
as his quote unquote best friend. This is everybody's going to
read this as total guilt. You totally rich and now you want a
virtue signal about him coming back. Oh yeah, come back rich.
We love you, buddy. We love you. But you couldn't stand on business
when it was tough, eh? >> Just move forward, I guess.
So, there are two options here, by the way. He's either a totally
hypocritical piece of human filth or he's seen way more evidence
that points to this being a pattern or just more conclusive with
regards to Rich that he will not tell anybody about and he's
going to virtue signal about being on Rich's side now. He's either
disgusting then or he's disgusting now. Most likely disgusting
in both instances that that he's just making this up here that
he is totally throwing his friend under the bus without concrete
evidence back here and then in the future he's going to pretend
he didn't do that. Didn't totally help and and stick like the
second or third blade into Rich's back. He's going to pretend
that didn't happen, right? So he can go later and say, "Oh, guys,
he's my friend. He really got screwed over. He got screwed over,
guys.
brother.
>> I don't I don't I don't know. I guess it's just time
to move forward. And that's pretty much all I can say about that.
I also want to say
honestly, I'm I'm very proud
with how OTK handled things.
Handled it in less than 30 minutes.
Great on them.
>> did they evaluate a lot of evidence? >> Know what
they needed to do and they didn't hesitate. Honestly, I'm not
an owner. I'm not a founder of OTK.
I am merely just a talent.
But to see that type of quick action
made me happy, right? It it it really made me feel like they
respected the situation. And that's hard. That feel like I'm
watching a different multiverse thread. I know. It's crazy how
much of a grifter this guy is. There's no consistent principle.
When this happened with Rich, I read through all this stuff.
I don't think I was streaming yet, right? No, I wasn't. No, I
wasn't streaming yet. that I was a year away from streaming.
I always was on I was like, "Dude, Rich shouldn't be cancelled.
OTK should stand by him. They they need to wait on like more
information coming out, right? They need to wait." That was my
opinion back then, at least based on the information that was
public. And I guess the thought was from other people, well,
enough stuff's come out privately to them that they're willing
to cut ties with Rich.
But now apparently the people who made those decisions who would
have been like I guess kept apprised of this situation overall
are all going back and saying well Rich got totally screwed over
guys. I you can't have it both ways. Had to have been hard. There's
a lot of other things we need to talk about. Uh but let's talk
about the noodle shop.
Obviously Rich being gone affects more than just himself.
And as you guys know the noodle shop. Obviously crying is breathing.
Crying is breathing. control your breath and you can stop crying.
>> So, there's a new Harry Potter game coming out. >> Yeah,
I'm going to scream. Just get out of my system. All right. >> This
was the noodle shop, by the way. I had no idea what the noodle
shop was. This is the noodle shop. Okay.
It's podcast with Emir,
Tactone, and Rich. Maybe they'll bring it back. Dude, dude, that's
crazy,
>> dude. That is nuts. Just This just further cements.
Okay, hold on. You get a wide shot. You get a wide shot of these
three at any point. >> I'm going to scream. >> Oh,
is there no wide shot? That's [__] nuts, dude. Emirou
People thought Emir was in danger at TwitchCon, okay? They'd
never seen this podcast before. It was definitely I I promise
you if we ever find that guy's follows, it's going to be an OTK
fan 100%. It's just obvious.
you guys know uh that Noodle Shop is my favorite thing. And obviously
you guys know that Rich was a huge part of Noodle Shop, but I
will just >> Yeah, he's the only person with any charisma
on that podcast.
>> Be completely legitimate. I'm going to do everything
that I possibly can to not let Noodle Shop end. I will be real.
We recorded three episodes of the Noodle Shop.
Those are not going to be
They were damn good episodes.
>> But they will not be released.
>> No. Is that in my power to do?
No. But I'm going to be trying literally everything
to make sure the Noodlers
still have something to watch.
Or let's
season two, >> aka Steak and Eggs. By the way, >> maybe.
Once again, I'm just a talent. Take that with a grain of salt.
But if it is entirely up to me, I don't want to give up on Noodle
Shop at all. >> Gives a whole new meaning to Rich constantly
saying his greatest fear was getting cancelled because he knew
what he did. Man, I love Teone. I think it's probably I think
it's probably my favorite member when he explains situations.
Please protect this guy. Update on this situation. She dropped
her accusations. I've decided to dismiss my lawsuit. Okay. Is
anybody going to know? I I really hope people start saying, "Wait,
why did you why did you do this? Why did you
Why did you do Why did you cancel Rich like this, bro? Why did
you go so hard? Why did you say he was guilty? Why did you imply
Why did you end your friendship with him instantly? Oh, good
call. Yeah. Sort by new.
Oh, it's only this. It's only this comment. That's it.
it's either going to be me or Emmy or me or Emmy and maybe somebody
new. Who knows? Or maybe it'll [__] and there's nothing
really I can do.
Maybe we'll rebrand and make a new podcast. I don't know.
But as far as it goes, that was something that I wanted to do
for my entire [__] life. >> Wow. Hold on. I'm
I'm reading ahead in the transcript. So if you see that every
>> Oh god. Again. Please be in the transcript. Please be
in the transcript. There's no miskif in the transcript.
Okay. Okay.
Oh man, you never really realize how much this [__]
affects you until you have to talk about it. Oh god.
I was literally this morning I was talking about how I wanted
to watch Parasite and Hellen. I was I was fine. I was fine, dude.
I thought I was going to come on here and clown around. I did
not realize I was so emotionally attached to [__]
brown noodle
party. [__] me, dude. I mean, I guess I have a lot
of [__] going on in my life right now, huh? Hey,
man. First the wife, then your best friend. I sure hope nothing
bad happens to my cats. Holy. >> I don't, bro. It's like
It's so funny when you hear him speaking off the cuff. You can
just see how every single situation, it's all with regards to
how he is the victim in that given at that given point in time,
right? It's so It's so crazy, guys. You never know how much this
affects you. First my wife, then my best friend. Everybody betrays
me.
>> I mean, you all know how people say that. Uh, hey, man.
He tone stories can't be real. I don't know what happens, bro.
Just bad follows me like the plague. Wait, I lost three of the
cats.
[__] me. >> Wait, what? >> All right.
>> Did you say he lost three of the cats?
>> Give me one second. I'm just going to get a tissue should
be right here. All right. Talked about Rich, talked about uh
the victim, talked about Noodle Shop, talked about the cats,
talked about the wife. Oh, man.
That's a lot to talk about. That's a lot. It's a lot, bro. There's
like so many people, okay, there's so many people who don't understand
like how bad the pileon effect is from these things that like
there's so many people like Techone here who don't have spines
and they're completely incentivized to just go with the mob
and it's so disgusting that he says he's Rich's best friend,
right?
Unless unless there was an overwhelming amount of evidence. How
in the do you go live and talk about how like up it is that your
best friend did this and how OTK made the right decision, right?
And how you're not friends with him anymore? How the do you do
that and then you come back a little bit later and go, "Oh, well,
she just lied about rape and moves on. No damage done to them.
Ruined a man's life for 3 years." Brother, what did you do in
3 years?
You You went live right after this story came out and threw your
your brother, your best friend under the bus, said you weren't
friends with him anymore. totally implied he was actually guilty
and you come out here and pretend you didn't do anything. Oh,
I'm so glad my buddy's going to be back, guys. My buddy's going
to be back. [__] crazy, man. It's It's actually baffling
that he feels comfortable like that he feels comfortable taking
the positions he does now. It's a lot for one stream, man.
It's a lot. Is there anything else that I haven't talked about
that I probably should have?
Oh, yeah. [__] Am I going on break?
No. Should I?
probably.
Do I want to? No.
I [__] love streaming. I love making >> dude.
I Oh, this is like the prelude to the Hassan thing. I can't even
I didn't even really think of it correctly. This is absolutely
just the prelude to the Hassan thing, right? He gets some new
information that like really doesn't make him the victim at all.
He makes himself the victim through sheer willpower and then
he cries and talks about how he was touched as a kid and that's
why he's crying now. It's like the exact same. Like literally
any talk about is going to make him relive those things. He's
going to cry and blame it on the person who did it, right? Blaming
rich here. Blame Cassan in the other case is wild. And when people
tell me to go on break, I don't know why I would want to go on
break and my favorite thing. I've been doing this for like 4
years, dog. It's one of the few things that actually makes me
happy.
It's like one of the few things that makes me feel
I have such a good chat. I have such a good community.
So, no, I really don't want to go on break. I just want to be
[__] I just want to be good and just [__]
>> Sorry. The music is off. The music is just not a fit
at all. Right. Super cozy Persona music >> just for a [__]
little bit, man. I don't know why so much bad happens around
me, dog. I feel like I'm cursed
>> I think we all see that. Yeah. I It's The curse is calling
or sorry, the curse is called being a horrible human being. That's
the curse, guys. It's almost like I'm It's almost like there's
something really bad going on around me. Like maybe I'm a terrible
person. Oh wow. >> Sorry, I'm spiraling a little bit. >> Okay,
if you're asking me. >> Oh well, that going on a break
statement aged well. It did. This is 2 years ago. Sorry, almost
3 years ago. 2 years 10 months ago is when this came out. Uh
did we get a Miskf statement? Was Miskf off at this point? I
think Miskf was gone, right? Msk couldn't really say anything
about Rich. Bisk was already on his like leave of absence,
I believe.
All right, we're going to cross over from that one to the Asmin
gold statement. Okay, we we have an Asmin gold statement as well.
Let's go give that a look. Oh, we got Hold on. We apparently
have uh possibly an XQC statement as well.
This one's not going to this one's not going to hit as hard.
Okay, I don't think so, but we'll maybe we'll look at it in a
little bit. So, I think everybody's pretty much seen the allegations
and everything. >> So, this video released same day as
the Techone video. Okay. >> Against Rich. Uh, if you haven't,
uh, I would suggest to just check our Twitter. Uh, and, you know,
we've obviously addressed this ourselves.
uh this came to our attention uh yesterday and
uh as soon as we pretty much found out and you know looked into
it and saw what was what was going on uh we had Rich resign from
the org and Rich is no longer a part of OTK
effective
>> Okay. So as soon as we became aware of this we had him
resign from the org
Did they No. No talk about whether or not it's like true, right?
Just the allegation came to light and they immediately made him
step down from the org is what I'm hearing. Now, from other people,
it sounds like we get more he's got more information. Asold has
more, but let him keep >> uh the reason I'm going to be
talking about it.
uh probably more than anybody else that is in the uh that that's
in the org is because the truth is Rich like he said was you
know my friend and uh I I want to talk about it on a personal
level and
I want to say a couple of things that uh I I I I've just really
got to say something about. Uh so uh
>> so I'm going to lay out how I think about Asmin Gold's
thinking here. I think Asminold has been seething about this
statement from the second he made it until the modern day. I
think Asminold was upset that with himself and with OTK that
he was pushed to make this statement and throw Rich under the
bus like he was. I think when he eventually made his post, his
like little speech about the Palestine comments, the genocide
comments, he had a little riff in there. I should try to find
it. Can we find that video? Uh the when he talked about genocide
and he apologized and he said, "I'm gonna go get I'm gonna go
be less angry." Oh, hold on.
Uh I didn't spell Palestine correctly. Hold on. Where is his
original my plans moving forward?
I think in this video somewhere in here, he talks about how
he wants to make a statement on certain things, but he's going
to have to leave it for later.
I somehow have Skitzosphere assembled these things. I think it's
been about this rich thing where he feels like he threw rich
under the bus without all of the with all the without all of
the facts that the other people in OTK made him do that and I
think he's been yeah seething about that since. I don't think
this is what he wanted to do and I think he was pushed to do
it because of the situation they were in with Msk and he's regretted
it ever since and he is like hellbent on not letting something
like this happen again which is why I think he's I honestly feel
like it's contributed a little bit to his political leanings
like his political um migration from this like really libertarian
type of guy towards more of a Trumper. I think I think this has
something to do with it.
Now, that's just me again. Schizosphere more than more than hard
evidence, more than anything. I do. Yes, that's that's what it
was watching it back.
They
protected the wrong person. I think this has a lot to do, by
the way. I think this has a lot to do with Asminold's total resentment
of Msk is that they defended Msk in a situation that was like
tough and then the rich stuff came out and they had no capital
left with their audiences to ever go and defend rich. And I think
Asminold blames Msk for Rich's situation to a large extent. >> I
mean, it it was a big shock to me. I think it was a shock to
everybody.
Uh it it's hard for me to process what's been going on.
And I understand that for a lot of people, you all who might
have been fans of of of Rich or AllCraft,
uh you might have have felt that way too. I I want to say one
thing though before I I I go any further. You are not on our
team. You are not helping us. You are not doing us any favors
or doing anyone any favors
>> by calling a girl that comes out and tells this kind
of a story a liar.
>> I read a lot of the comments on Twitter,
and I saw a lot of people that were saying that it wasn't true,
uh, that she's making everything up. Please do not do that.
Th this is you. You are not our fan. You're not on our side.
We are on their >> This is all like fine. You could you
could say this. I don't think And the sad thing is I think when
you do the PR speak, they don't tell you like you could easily
just say, "Hey, hold up. Don't make a decision on this now. Let
it play out over time. Please just accept the ambiguity of the
situation." I know it doesn't feel good to accept that ambiguity,
right? Feels horrible. actually feels horrible to think that
this guy could be really bad, but I need to wait to make a decision.
But that's exactly what you need to do as a good person. You
need to wait, right?
In in like this kind of situation, you need to let facts come
out. You need to let it all come out over time. And I I think
I don't remember if he does that here. If he ever goes back to
try to try to give Rich any kind of life raft, I hope he doesn't
quite go as hard as Tee does cuz Teone sold him down the river,
right? Maybe maybe Asen Gold will do a little bit more. Oh, actually,
hold on. What was the what was the tense he used? Hold on. Friend.
When he said friend, oh, he passed test. >> The truth is
Rich, like he said, was, you know, my friend. And
Dude, these guys are
Listen, I don't think he lives up to the moniker very often,
but that's a roach maneuver right there, isn't it? That's why
Rich is gone
>> on Twitter, etc.
>> Uh that she's making everything up. >> Okay, we'll
listen to this one more >> Please do not do that.
Th this is so just I I I don't think Aspen Gold will make any
further statements on this cuz I think as a part of the OTK litigation,
whatever was going on there, I think she I think he's going to
have to stay quiet as well. But don't let anybody from this from
around this time who's trying to signal out like their politics
now like Techone, don't let them convince you that, oh, it's
all the woman's fault. She destroyed his life. No, you all sold
him down the river instantly trying to keep your bag going. All
right. Should I stand on business or should I should I stand
on business and risk my money? No. No. My best friend, that guy.
No. No. Get him out of here. Get him out of here. He's not worth
anything to me. >> You You are not our fan. You're not
on our side.
We are on their side.
That's why rich is gone. Do not do this.
Uh I I I understand trust but verify. Makes sense. Everybody
deserves to get their their side of the story out, but whenever
you just automatically discredit one side, you're not looking
for two sides. You're looking for the other side.
>> Okay, that's a little more neutral. >> Do not
do that. >> Like to see it >> and call call yourself
a fan of mine or anybody in the org. The second thing I want
to say is that if anybody is in any way responsible for this,
it's it it's me. I I I knew Rich more than anybody else. And
because of that,
>> if you have any
if you feel like you've been betrayed and and you you've been
led to believe something that's not true, please don't take this
out on any of the other people in our org, any of our employees,
any of the people that we work with.
Let me tank it.
Direct your hate at me. >> Oh, the XQC maneuver. Okay.
the the PR
the third thing I want to say is that
I read everything.
I also know a few other things as well.
Uh-oh.
This is not drama. This is not getting cancelled. These are crimes.
Bro, I'm sorry. Like,
you got to understand, you got to understand how sensitive the
situation is, right? given
if you say you have this kind of evidence, right? You got to
stand on it and you got to stand on it later. You have to say
later. You can never go back and say, "Oh, no, no, no." Like,
"She was a total liar." If you want to say this now that there
are crimes happening, you've seen evidence of crimes, you've
seen more than what's public, you got to stand on this, right?
You can't go back. I don't want people to go in and call these
this is drama.
It's not drama. This is serious. It is as serious as it gets.
I took action as soon as I could and I I I >> No, we don't
have any proof she lied at all at Tequila Sunset. There's nothing
like that. There's nothing like proof that she lied.
>> I I I don't know.
>> Unless, sorry. Unless one of the pieces of evidence
she provided to these people that they're saying they have was
an outright lie from her. I But I obviously wouldn't have any
way to speculate on that. I wouldn't have that evidence.
>> Just sucks, man. >> Yes. Hold on, Top Bronson.
This is what takes it from an allegation that people could say,
"Well, we have to wait to, oh, Asminold and Teone got rid of
their best friend. They they walked away from their best friend,
right? That's why I don't want this Techone
to get away with, oh, this whole shift up where it's all the
girl's fault." No, Teone, you came out and said you were dropping
this mother instantly. All right. So, you either had some evidence
that she was telling the truth or you're a totally you're a totally
princ unprincipled
unprincipled wretched liar who's willing to grift on whatever
whatever you think. Sorry. You're willing to grift in whatever
direction the wind blows, right? Is crazy.
In 30 minutes, they decided in 30 minutes. Uh yeah, that's what
they said, Sophia. Or that's what Tee said was he he gave them
credit for making the decision and having Rich step down within
30 minutes. But I will say it's possible they had more information
before this happened, right? That the person had approached OTK
first or something. It's possible. >> Sucks. I don't even
want to talk about how it's >> uh sorry again. I will go
back though. You are right that if they did do it within 30 minutes
and actually stream dad is also right here. It would be a huge
red flag if it was like within 30 minutes they made this this
decision, right? Massive red flag. >> Sucks. I don't even
want to talk about how it's made me feel because I think that
takes attention away from the actual people who are the victims
here. It'll take me a while to get over this, but I will get
over it.
I learned last year that I can get through anything. It doesn't
matter.
I can take it. I can deal with it. So if you want to give somebody
support, >> give the people who are brave enough to come
out and tell their story
whenever they're being attacked
by people who think that they're doing me or somebody else a
favor,
do not do that. I don't know what else I can do. If there's anything
that you guys would like to see me do, I'm I'm open for suggestions.
I I feel there's a part of me that feels a genuine sense of guilt
and uh I I'd like to do something. I don't know what it is. I
don't know what I can do. >> Man, the tough thing the actual
tough thing that you needed to do back here if this guy was really
your friend was say, "Listen, this looks concerning. The org
needs to separate from him because of like reputational concerns,
but we don't know all the facts yet, and I need to I'm going
to stick by my friend until all the facts come out. That's it.
But um that's what's been going on. And um you know, you have
a situation like this and you go through every message, every
interaction you have and you always wonder like, oh maybe like
was it maybe should I have known something different or should
I have you know been able to like perceive? >> Wait, what
what was Rich saying to you that you could have Wait, what what
messages are you re-evaluating? What the [__] Wait,
what? Why are you like I'm sorry if you go live after your friends
accuse you hold a funeral service for them and the reputation
and your your org.
Yeah, people are going to get this impress like you guys fed
this. You guys made it real. You guys made it so real. So guaranteed
so locked in. >> Give some sort of thing. And there's just
a lot of things that go through my head and um uh I'm going to
be a bit shook for this for a while.
Um, but I I thought that it was right for me to come out and
uh address this directly to you guys and to our our fans and
viewers and everything
and just echo what you know we said in our statement is that
we share in your disappointment. It sucks. Again, Rich is completely
out of the orc. That's it. Yep. I I I'm pretty sure I I feel
like I've I've said everything that I I've wanted to say. Um,
>> uh, this is what I mean, man. Snake, this is what I
mean, man. Snake behavior. There's no no way he was pushed to
take this strong of a stance. This was a choice. I mean, it was
a choice. I do think he was pushed. I absolutely think like the
their like whatever their executive, their board or whatever
would have come together and pushed to make this choice. Um,
he might have made it more willingly than I thought. I do think
that after the fact he's renderivized this as in he was pushed
and he had no choice. >> Again, uh
two things I I want to just reiterate one more time
is that if you go and you are messaging these girls trying to
cast dispersions, cast a shadow of doubt and make them feel bad
for coming forward with what their story is. You are not our
fan. You're not my fan. You're not doing us any favors. You're
not on our team. You're not helping us. You're not helping anyone.
Do not do that. If I see people doing that in my chat, I will
ban them. I think everybody should do the same. Also,
again, OTK has a lot of employees.
We have other people like um you know, like our other talent
that are on the org too, streamers.
They know nothing about this. They have nothing to do with this.
even uh other owners, if if you feel like like something wrong,
bring it to me. Bring it to me directly. And yeah, let let me
tank it. I can deal with it.
And so uh I encourage any of the uh any of the people that were
affected uh by by uh by Rich and any any of these things uh to
seriously consider uh legal recourse.
And of course, if that happens, I will comply in any way I can,
limited as it may be. Again, this is not drama. These this is
these could be actual crimes.
>> So, um I think that's about all I have to say. I'm going
to be honest. I I I think that's about it. >> Thank you,
Asmin Gold. >> I I can't answer a hundred different
Uh I I don't want to do that because
obviously I don't want to compromise other people's uh privacy
or anything like that. Uh, I think that, you know, obviously,
you know, we'll see what's going to happen. I think that's what
happens with that that's that's the way it goes with almost anything.
And I just hope that uh I hope everything's okay. I mean, that's
really all there is to it. Take the day off. I mean, I uh and
I understand there are some people that have questions and um
I I don't want to go through and explain everything >> Hey,
sorry. I'm just waiting for like tangible
statements that I can engage with in some way. He's kind of I
I don't blame him. Obviously, this is right on the back of the
Misk stuff, so he's probably like kind of
He probably feels kind of Is Rich coming back to OTAA? No, I
don't think so, sweatpants. But, um, yeah, he's he's kind of
like stun locked right now going around in circles. Again, a
lot of these things are very serious and I just don't want to
do that. I I want to
just let let the let the evidence and everything speak for itself.
I don't want to make uh assumptions or anything like that. So,
don't just tank it alone. I mean, it's it's fine. Uh it's it's
fine. So, yeah. Uh it's about it. I appreciate all you guys being
supportive of me and uh everything, too. Uh obviously, I've seen
a lot of the uh messages you all have sent me, etc. And I really
appreciate it. Obviously, it's been uh it's been comforting and
so thank you to everybody.
>> Wow. Um,
that's that's about it. I mean, I I I not really >> I I'm
just glad he didn't talk about how this was happening to him,
how it was so up this is all happening to him. Okay. He said,
"Listen, you want to blame somebody, you can blame me." You see
the difference? This is why this guy doesn't suck anywhere near
like this guy has like some awareness, some stuff going on that
makes him seem pretty spooky to me. Tect is just a totally wretched
creature that I
have no I don't have anything I think I could learn from Tee.
I think you could learn things from Asmin Gold. Not necessarily
good things about politics, but I think there are lessons you
could take from Asmin Gold. From Techone, it's like uh just every
part of this person is so sure like what exactly I'm going to
do today.
I have no idea. Uh but
yeah, uh that's that's about it. And um in terms of like I know
a lot of people will want to make like comments about this or
or say stuff about this. Uh I I understand like people want to
process things, but I'm going to try to avoid like any of the
uh uh like memes or or stuff like that. I I don't want to deal
with that. Uh to be honest, it just Yeah, I don't want to deal
with it. Hold on. Okay. Well, there's the there's the Asmin Gold
statement. All right. We got the Asmin Gold statement. I might
take a quick look at the XQC stuff. What is he going to read
the whole thing? If he reads Oh, XQC's got the text messages
here. Nice.
Oh, good. Good. We got some uh >> we got some text messages.
Okay,
>> we got the we could read the original text messages.
I'm going to let him read for just a second. I'm grabbing some
caff. Give me two seconds. >> Like it was like we're doing
an investigator any today. I guess
>> uh friends is at the bar. If you want to hang out later,
let me know. I was already in bed. Lol. I with you, but it's
okay if you're not already in bed. Would you want to come and
chill here? It's okay. I don't think it's something I'm good
with. Okay. Love to see you. Too bad you're already out of commission,
but no worries. What do I do? Oh, whatever. Little movie theater
in my building. You want to chill there? Have a trick in me to
go out this late, but what if you could chill?
>> Hey, I'm looking. I'm looking. I'm looking. Yo.
Um, we could chill. It's not my apartment. Yeah, we could probably
do that. Cool. I want to come.
>> Do you guys uh are you guys not >> I'm here. Goodbye.
Cool. What time you thinking? Not sure,
>> guys. Anything in there or not? Okay. I see you. I'm
going to stay up. I'm so seriously if it's too late, it's not
a problem. Lol. I I don't want you to wait around if you're going
to bed. Um, I'll wait. Send me a pick. It'll help me stay
>> Uhhuh. viciously.
>> This is the part where I remember this one where it's
like Rich Rich says something that's clearly flirty and he follows
it up. She doubles down or sorry, he follows it up. He doubles
down. What? I want to see your face. And then she sends him a
peace sign. >> Do you still want me to come by? I just
paid at the bar. Yeah. Address.
What time? Dropping off
in the village.
>> Okay. Is that okay? >> You guys understand? Also,
you could just read. Okay. I should just come over. Okay.
>> How the [__] did XCC get so famous when
he sounds drunk all the time? Can you guys chill? You guys uh
one, he was like the best Overwatch player ever, okay, at Winston.
And two, he's really entertaining. Okay,
he's just massively he's super entertaining when he was popping
off playing video games.
>> All right, I'll be there. Cool. See you soon. Hi, I'm
here. Coming.
>> Like, in a lot of ways, all right, in a lot of ways,
12:46 a.m. 12:46 a.m. to go like meet and hang out and watch
a movie platonically
is kind of
that's tough, right? That's tough to feel like that was all she
wanted. Now, that doesn't mean you could just [__]
this person without asking for their consent, obviously, and
things could have still gone badly. But I do believe that she
probably went there thinking, "Okay, we might be hooking up.
>> I'm okay. I'm looking if I'm out here or we're in the
same city. We can catch up and hang out. Wait, is this is this
in chronological order?
There something with you. I'm taking a trip. But there's really
Okay, I'll read this one for you. Okay, I'll
>> do you take a trip really stand for
>> Okay, this is her. If I'm out there or we're in the
same city, we can catch up and hang out. If there was some sort
of consistency with you, I'd consider getting a hotel and taking
a trip. But that's not But there's not. I mean, let's be honest.
You don't even call me when you say you're going to. And then
Oh, and that you really want to talk to me and then you disappear
for days. I'm not trying to get on your case because at this
point, I honestly don't care and I have no expectations. But
outside of being friends, I don't see anything happening. Full
transparency, I've been celibate for over two years. So, I'm
not just uh I'm not just hooking up or sleeping around with people
and I'm personally looking for a situation where someone cares
about me and wants to put in effort towards me. And he said,
"I want to start effort with each other. I really want to see
you. Let's figure something out." So, he is literally he's leaning
into the thing that she's saying here, right? Like that is proof
of especially if he asked her to leave after they have
that's proof that he's kind of just being a total scumbag here,
right? for one true King Kalalal. >> I mean, let's be honest.
You know when you call me when you say you're going to and that
you really want to talk and disappear for days. I'm not sure
because at this
>> Wait, can we just find more clips of XQC? Can we find
XQC reading like a couple pages of Harry Potter cuz I feel like
that I just suddenly realized what there's some awesome reacts
that could be had. All right, I just want XQC reading any children's
novel out there. Any young adult novel? Let's go right now. Load
it up. >> I'm having thisations, but outside of seeing
friends, I don't see anything. I've been in folders.
I've been celibate for over two years. I'm just
hooking up
>> this. He takes breaks where he's reading like he's about
to drop into a halfpipe for the first time in his life. You guys
ever drop into a halfpipe and you're just like you're just not
used to that like angle downwards? You remember the first time
you ever like looked down? I feel like that's what I hear from
XQC when he goes to read certain words. He's like hooked up.
>> Been celibate for over 2 years. I'm just
hooking up with or sleeping. >> He like takes that break
before he drops >> around with people and I'm personally
looking for a situation where someone cares about me and wants
to put effort in towards me. I'm going to start effort with each
other. Everyone see the outs. I don't think I can. I'm too okay.
I care about your >> Got to lay off the scumbag, man. It's
losing its meaning. Desi is a scumbag for crimes. No, Desi is
like an inhuman
totally immoral mutant lizard.
So that that's fine. You're just you're you're softening it with
scumbag. It's not scumbag is probably not a accurate enough word
there. Frenzy freeze. Rich is like a scumbag here. This is like
a scumbag move. You're just lying, right? Lying is bad. We as
we always say, lying bad. Lying sucks.
>> Get that per that person have the feelings. Stop reading
private messages. You're rant. Well, they're not really private.
I mean, they're literally being put out to be read. >> No,
just stop reading. I can't handle it. Uh, I don't think I can.
I'm too attracted to you. Okay, I care about you a lot, but it's
a lie if I say I'm not absurdly attracted to you. I get that,
but I'm a person and have feelings, lol. I know, and I care about
you as a person. When we when we have that type of relationship,
it doesn't feel like that to me. I know it doesn't, but I genuinely
think it's just because we were so different in those ways. And
I don't think it's either of our faults.
Well, well, the messages are literally being being put out publicly
by the person who wants them to be read,
>> which is fair enough. >> Wait, you understand
I'm saying the the scumbag part isn't the assault. You're not
a scumbag for assaulting somebody, Frenzy Freeze. I think your
your understanding of scumbag and what I think scumbag is really
off. Okay, you're a scumbag if you like lie to people to manipulate
them into doing things for you. That's like scumbag
piece of kind of an [__] There's all the words together,
right? If you're insulting people or raping people, that's way
different. You There's a higher word there. Oh, reply to somebody
else. I got you, >> guys. I don't know what the Dude, why
is making memes? >> Okay. The statements made against me
today. I will share a message story, but need some time to collect
my thoughts. OD has requested that I resign my position, and
I've agreed I will make an update soon. >> I got to see
what his reaction is. >> Wait a minute. There's a big difference,
>> dude. He's like first to the tweet. >> Okay. There's
a big difference between resigning and being asked to resign
and stepping down and taking a temporary
>> Yeah, obviously. >> Right.
It seems to me Okay, I have to choose my words properly.
Wait,
I have to choose my choose properly here. >> Definitely
guilty.
So then because
I guess if they believed it to be
If they believed to be if they believed it to be untrue
and oh look the exact thing I said was happening because of Teone
and Asmin Gold and the OTK response. We watch it happen on XQC's
face, right? We watch him walk through his thought process. Well,
if they didn't think this was true, they wouldn't ask him to
resign.
Yeah. They literally tipped this against Rich. They totally Rich.
>> He was gonna he was going to put up a a valid good defense.
I assume that they would just ask him to like temporarily step
down. Is that how that works? But if they think it's like an
unwinable case or it's not worth the trouble, they just drop
him entirely. I I'm Guys, I'm I'm more like asking a question
here. Oh my god, bro. What the is in? No, they didn't. No, they
didn't. Miskf did not resign at least stepped down temporarily
from his duties as a co uh whatever.
>> Yo, this is X X on the beat. Yo,
>> You my voice as well. >> That ass. >> Anyone
knows that boy?
>> I don't know. He's just so >> man.
Oh, the sad boy. That's a That's a vibe that hits me in the nostalgia
right there. I watch I was an XQC viewer for like a couple months
or something around the time of the Minecraft stuff. Okay. I
was I I liked him. He's he once you get used to understanding
him, it's like a vibe stream. It's good. It's good stuff.
You have to get used to understanding him though. No, it's a
it's a good experience. Dude, if you didn't watch the Minecraft
runs, you are a total loser. You You missed out on some of the
best content ever. Some of the stuff between him and uh Orson.
Great. Yeah. Yeah, sad. Very sad. Okay, I think that's that's
about it for the rich stuff. I don't know if there's a whole
lot more there. If you if you don't use it, you lose it. Understanding
X, I can still understand him. Where's the rich update? Well,
we already had it. Sweatpants freedom. Did you you missed it?
It's uh the person who was suing